Sentimientos encontrados aquí en París
en este paso de Francia la final de esta
Copa del Mundo de Qatar 2022 en un
primer momento parecía que era los
marroquíes los que hacían más ruido en
la capital francesa recordemos son más
de un millón los que viven en Francia
estaban muy seguros de hacer historia
llegar por primera vez a la final de una
copa del mundo sin embargo ya cuando
hubo el segundo tanto de los franceses
la desilusión fue visible casi hasta las
lágrimas muchos de ellos abandonaron los
lugares donde estaban siguiendo este
partido y dijeron simplemente que
estaban muy contentos con el desempeño
histórico hecho por sus elecciones
escuchemos lo que nos dijeron marroquíes
y franceses después de este partido
histórico
estoy muy muy muy emocionado de que
Francia haya ganado estamos aquí con los
amigos y vamos a ganar la tercera
estrella la tercera estrella
feliz noche
[Música]
sí yo estaba apoyando a Marruecos y
estoy muy muy triste
fue un gran recorrido y también un gran
logro
y ahora Estamos muy tristes y Tendremos
que apoyar a Francia era un partido bajo
unas estrictas medidas de seguridad
Diez mil policías y andarme movilizados
en toda Francia un cuarto de ellos solo
en París para evitar desórdenes el fin
de semana pasado el sábado cuando
Marruecos y Francia se clasificaron
había en total 20,000 personas en los
campos elíseos esta noche han sido sin
duda mucho más pero lo más importante es
el espíritu de los marroquíes que pese a
la derrota siguen haciendo la fiesta
aquí en la capital francesa